so then we begin by by introducing
everyone here on the end we have dr.
Michael Denton who is a professor of
human genetics at the University of
information technology in islamabad next
to him we have dr. Clive win who is a
associate professor of psychology at the
great University of Florida and also the
author of do animals think do animals
think can animals think do a new do
animals think and then we have Michael
Shermer who is the founder of skeptic
magazine and columnist for Scientific
American and the author of several books
the most recent being why Darwin matters
the case against intelligent design so
what I'd like to do to start is if is
have each of you step forward and maybe
tell us a little bit about your most
recent book and perhaps the most
provocative thesis that you have in that
book so why don't we start with you
Michael Shermer good thank you okay
there is a god it's just shocked me so i
am michael shermer the director of the
skeptic society and the publisher of
skeptic magazine as you know we
investigate claims the paranormal
pseudoscience fringe groups and cults
and claims of all kinds between science
and pseudoscience and junk science and
pathological science and bad science and
non science and plain old nonsense and
you know that's the sort of our themes
any particular kind of controversy is it
true is it not does it have some effects
does it not can you measure it can you
test it so my first book on why people
believe we're things was basically how
we go about doing that what our baloney
detection kit is that is how we apply
the tools of skepticism and reason and
science to try to decide as something as
real or not and often case for example
one can be a skeptic of a claim or a
skeptic of the skeptics of a claim we
did an investigation of the Holocaust
deniers who consider themselves skeptics
of the Holocaust and we ended up being
skeptical of the skeptics which I guess
makes us true believers or something
like that but the idea is that is not a
position you stake out it's a
just a tool of investigating things you
can be a skeptic of global warming or
you can be a skeptic of the skeptics of
global warming that sort of thing
sometimes we've found in our
investigations like in the investigation
of chiropractic and acupuncture
acupressure the whole idea the theory
behind it is probably nonsensical that
there's a human energy field that flows
and it gets stuck at different chakras
and if you can adjust the chakras it
will release the energy and improve
health and and that sort of thing and
now it's possible that being poked and
prodded and massaged and adjusted does
have beneficial effects for health and
wellbeing for reasons other than what
the theory says about the energy fields
and that kind of thing so I'll give you
an example like if I was to make an
adjustment of my own neck and and if you
could if you listen quietly you might be
able to hear it and so we can see how it
works even if it doesn't have anything
to do with that energy field ok here we
go see listen let's see if you can hear
it oh oh man okay that's why that really
does work anyway so I just thought I'd
wake up the afternoon audience there um
so but but it's not just medical claims
or paranormal claims from there I
branched off into a second book on how
we believe about the role of religion
and myths and storytelling and the power
of belief and and that you know
naturally led people to ask wow you're
dealing with you know the afterlife and
God stuff like that what is your
position on the afterlife and I usually
say well you know I'm for it but of
course what were for and what's real may
not always be the same so that leads
into the study of the psychology of
belief and it turns out for example that
most of us most of the time believe what
we believe about economics and politics
and religion based on where we were born
and what our parents believed in what
our peer groups believe in what our
mentors and teachers and authors that
we've read believe we're heavily
influenced by others because we're so
social and so you can't discount the
the role of a psychology and sociology
and determining what it is that that we
believe and and so of course that it
does apply and this is where I'm going
in my latest book why Darwin matters
applying the rules of science to the big
questions about the origins of life and
why things look design and that sort of
thing but but ultimately where I'm
heading in the next book by what I'm
calling the fourth volume of my trilogy
as it were is as a book called the mind
of the market we're supposed to say
something about what our books are since
book TV is a beyond january of 08 the
mind of the market is about sort of
applying those same set of tools of
science and skepticism to the market and
see how the market works how the market
has seemed to have a mind of its own how
how minds operate in markets for example
the fact that we were spent ninety-nine
percent of our history as the species in
the small hunter-gatherer groups of a
couple dozen to a couple hundred
individuals where they were largely
galit Aryan and there's almost no wealth
at all there's no little very little
trade very little division of labor
nothing like the kind of world we live
in today no wonder people resent free
markets don't understand the invisible
hand what you can't see it's invisible
after all you don't trust what you don't
trust you fear and what you fear you
loathe this it goes a long ways to
explaining this evolutionary economics
model there's a long ways to explaining
why people are skeptical of free markets
why they don't trust entrepreneurs and
businessmen because often in either in
small evolutionary groups or in even in
human history large disparities of
wealth probably were ill-gotten and so
therefore we should be distressful and
skeptical the whole notion of a modern
economy generating more wealth for more
people is counterintuitive and it
requires education and conferences like
this and books and so on it you really
have to sell it it doesn't come
naturally and intuitively so in
conclusion that's sort of my stick
science applied to as many areas as we
can just to see you know where the chips
fall where the data falls and what we
can learn along the way because we're
all in this journey together to try to
make some sort of sense out of this
complex and
attic world thanks my name is Clive win
i'm the author most recently of do
animals think into animals think i argue
that the way that animals relate to the
world is radically different from the
way that we relate to the world and i
think the people who believe the
chimpanzees are thinking just like we do
are sorely mistaken there's very obvious
evidence for that if you invite a
chimpanzee into this room you will find
the chimpanzee doesn't understand
anything that's going on even one of the
chimpanzees who spent over 20 years in
training to up to understand human
language simply cannot make sense of
grammar the glue that makes our language
so infinitely powerful you can invite a
chimpanzee to beg for food chimpanzees
love begging for food they beg from each
other and they will beg from their
caretakers and you can offer a
chimpanzee a choice would you prefer to
beg for food from somebody who's looking
at you or from somebody who has a bucket
over their head chimpanzees do not
distinguish between somebody who's
looking at them and somebody who has a
bucket over her head it just makes no
difference to a chimpanzee my point is
not to suggest that chimpanzees are
stupid far from it my point is that the
way other species think is radically
different from how we think other animal
species do wonderful things honey beans
can communicate to each other three
dimensions of experience by dancing
imagine being able to communicate by
dancing it wouldn't that be an amazing
thing dolphins and bats can see their
way through darkness by using sonar and
they were doing this for thousands of
years before we figured out how to make
our own artificial sonar systems we only
discovered that they were doing it after
we invented it for ourselves and all of
a sudden had equipment that could detect
these sounds that are unavailable to the
human ear that are far too high-pitched
for the human ear to hear
so other species have wonderful ways of
relating to the world and if I'm going
to try and predict the future of science
in this area of understanding animal
minds it's going to be that we're going
to be continuously surprised that
something that comes naturally to us
just doesn't figure in the lives of
other animals but the things that are
completely alien to us and that a
difficult for us to imagine turn out to
play important roles in the lives of
other species I can't predict exactly
what these will be it's in the nature of
the thing we're blind two ways of
thinking ways of relating to the world
that we doubt ourselves share so it's a
very difficult thing to do to encompass
work I also think and I was reminded by
this by one of Michael schirmer's talks
yesterday morning where he showed a
wonderful video of half a dozen people
playing catch with a ball and while
they're playing catch with a ball
somebody dressed in a gorilla suit walks
through the midst of them I'm remarkable
I knew what to expect i saw the gorilla
the vast majority of people in the room
did not see the gorilla because they
have been invited by michael to pay
close attention to the catching of the
balls and two count how often each ball
was thrown in court that's called a form
of attentional blindness and I think
it's one of the most exciting
discoveries in psychology of the last 15
years that people talk about the
elephant in the room the concept or the
notion that is behind the scenes but
that nobody will enunciate well we
should talk about the gorilla in the
room the physically present things that
people are blind to and I think this is
phenomenally difficult science to do how
can you uncover the kinds of blindness
that the human mind has because you have
a human mind to you have no other tool
with which to go searching for this
blindness so it's extremely difficult
but I am confident that that will be one
of the developments of science in the
area of human minds in the future so I
think that the science of
mine's what I've written about and do
animals think we will uncover more ways
that animal minds are different from
human minds the science of human minds
we will discover more ways that human
minds are closed off to certain kinds of
information and the future of technology
going to make a very bold prediction
here I am confident that somebody will
invent a new I something that's my
prediction my name is Mike Denton when
my latest book is a book called nature's
destiny in which i take the fine-tuning
argument of the physicists into the
biological sciences and argue that
nature is not just fine-tuned for
planets for complex chemistry for stars
and galaxies but actually fine-tuned for
biological phenomena and may even be
fine-tuned for organisms very close to
ourselves so it's an extension of the
anthropic sort of position right into
the biological sciences the reason that
in fact i was led to the composing and
thinking about this book was that for
many many years have been skeptical
about classic darwin in explanations for
evolution in my academic career i've
watched for example the story of the
origin of life and i haven't seen any
real progress applying conventional
Darwinian explanation as to the origin
of life and I've also been extraordinary
interested ever since my PhD days long
ago and King's College in London where I
was interested in developmental biology
have been fascinated in the abstract
patterns in nature the shape of a maple
leaf the deep homologies which permai
permeate the whole of nature the fact
for instance that every all mammals have
seven cervical vertebrae what is
imposing on nature the constraints which
lead to these highly persistent patterns
for millions and millions of years the
fact the patterns are so abstract think
of the maple leaf think of how it
contrasts
the oakleaf yet both both both trees
standing side by side in the same
temperate forests the maple leaf has
remained virtually unchanged for a
hundred million years the Samaras the
adaptive device which carries the maple
seed away from the tree has varied quite
a lot so the adapt adaptations very lot
but the maple leaf if the strange
geometric pattern goes through time
unchanged so I've always been very
skeptical that the functionalist theory
of Darwin will really fully explain
these patterns in nature but how to
explain them basically the way to
explain them is to go back to some form
of the natural philosophy which was
founded by Goethe and popular in the
continent of Europe before the Darwinian
revolution but then how to go from as it
were nature to biology and then when I
was through the years when I've been
working as a geneticist over the last 20
years became I was also interested in
the growing evidence presented by
physicists over and over again that the
universe was fine tuned for four stars
galaxies and things of this and so I
thought well perhaps this fine tuning
could ultimately explain some of these
things which Darwinism seems to leave
unexplained in biology and so in fact
basically my position is that in fact
there is design in the biological realm
which is derived from the laws of nature
so I'm echoing here I great I'm echoing
something which was very popular before
Darwin and I think the this design is
imposed in biology by a fine tuning of
the laws of nature towards life as we
see it and still of course it doesn't
leave the details of how this is done to
be worked out but if you can show a step
number one that the world is fine-tuned
for life as we see it on earth and
perhaps even beings like our self this
is a huge step towards looking for the
additional fine-tuning that might impose
on nature those factors involved in the
origin of life
and the factors which generated these
extraordinary patterns in the natural
world so I I'm proposing in a sense a
form of intelligent design but the
design is coming from the very fabric of
nature itself it's not a design imposed
or brought into nature from outside by a
series of miraculous events the design I
see behind evolution which works with
the selection asst principal of Darwin
is coming from the very nature of things
themselves from the deepest fabric the
deepest ground of being that's my book
nature's destiny it's an attempt to move
into the biological rellin the ideas of
the physicists that the world is
fine-tuned for life thank you thank you
Michael now all three of you have
written very different books and yet
you're all three of you have written a
great deal about evolution and this
morning Michael you said to the audience
that the fact of evolution is
incontestable and yet in the United
States the vast majority over over half
of Americans simply don't believe in
evolution so my question to the panel is
why is this the case and is this likely
to change in the future well obviously
it's a you know culture-bound thing
because this is not the case in most
other countries so obviously there's
politics and religion and things that
influence and that was my previous point
the power of belief is there also i
think as i mentioned evolution is
counterintuitive you know since we
evolved in an environment which things
move relatively slowly you know lance
and antelopes they sort of run around we
kind of see them and some things like
the speed of light or the slow movement
of continents things like that we were
not adapted to detect those so they're
counterintuitive that's why continental
drift and and the idea of the speed of
light and all that is just that hard to
grasp or on the scale of say small
subatomic particles and atoms to
galaxies and bubble universes and so on
again we didn't evolve to have any
experience with those kinds of things
so they're counterintuitive and likewise
with time we live a scant few decades
and that's it so that's our experience
of time so the idea of global climate
change over 10,000 years what are you
talking about it was cold last week at
global warming would they that's how we
intuitively think of just sort of
short-term the idea of things changing
over millions of years you don't see
that in your daily life so there's
nothing to hook into it in our brains to
sort of grasp it intuitively whereas
intelligent design as a concept is
immediately graspable everybody gets it
yes we have lots of experience with
intelligently designed things and we
know it was an intelligent designer who
made it or relatively intelligent anyway
yeah i think i would agree entirely with
what michael says I would just expand
and say that to some extent the
resurgence of creationism in the United
States as opposed to most other
developed nations where of course there
are creationists but not at the same not
of this not with the same voice is is a
somewhat perhaps unfortunate side effect
of an otherwise extremely positive
aspect of life in the United States and
that is that there is continuous free
debate and lack of respect for for given
authority you know people are willing to
take on scientists and and by and large
that is broadly a force for good but it
leads to odd little things like this
from time to time I don't think we're at
any risk of anything like lie sinkhole
ism we're in the Soviet Union in the
1930s evolutionary biology was sidelined
for a generation because of Stalin's
crazy support for a for a completely
bogus biological scientist I don't I
don't think things could come to that
here yeah I think there's one
interesting point as well and that is
that one reason which might give
creationists some reason to sort of you
know interpret the biological world in
terms of creationism is it might turn
out but for instance the origin of life
and the origin for instance of the five
fingers in the hand was a result of
relatively saltation events for instance
in the case of the development of the
hand there are three phases of what the
call hox genes expression and the third
the third phase generates the
but it's quite clear that the digit
haven't evolved from the fins of a fish
they are new quite a new innovation in
evolution and a new gene expression
system same really applies to the
feather and so we may well be it may
turn out it if if there are as I think
self-organizing aspects to the
evolutionary process these could be
quite quick and so it might turn out
that when we eventually can explain the
whole of evolution we find that in fact
it's much more salt ational than has
been conventional among biologists and
this I think the fact that you can't in
many cases in the case of the thin two
digit transition is he you can't
actually and probably will never
actually be able to give a pure
Darwinian gradually bit by bit entirely
bit by bit explanation for the these
innovations I think this is one of the
facts about nature which is giving
creationism as sort of a you know it's
it's it's you can use the this salt
ational aspect to support it to some
extent you know I mean I think that it
all these if there are sold stations I
think they'll all be fully explained in
terms of natural lower self
organizational processes and things like
this let me ask you about Michael your
your biography for this event says that
your book evolution a theory in crisis
is a foundational texts of the
intelligent design movement the
intelligent design movement being of
course the idea that evolution can't be
explained in in purely naturalistic
terms but that there needs to be an
intelligent designer that that nature is
in some ways irreducibly complex yeah
and I and I've noticed that the
Discovery Institute and other
creationist or intelligent design
advocates quote your work at length are
you are you aware of this are you
comfortable with it if you asked him to
stop what is your thought on this I
haven't asked anybody to stop and I'm
not that comfortable with it partly
because in fact if the book should have
the book should have been called
Darwinism etherion crisis because I do
think that Darwinism is now in a long
term crisis I don't think you can
explain the whole biological world in
terms of tiny adaptive classic Darwinian
mechanisms right so that's that's one
thing I should have probably have called
the book that right in the first chapter
was Genesis rejected so I mean I tried
to make it obvious that I was coming to
this subject rejecting the traditional
biblical view how things came about on
the other hand as well my views have
changed since the mid-80s my views have
changed and some of the things in fact I
some of the arguments are proposing that
were probably slightly forced from the
vigorous about discontinuity in nature
but I still do believe that were as I've
said when we do work out I hadn't
discovered self-organization then
because that was I evolution here in
Christ was written before this these
ideas started to come out i mean i knew
the cell membrane was self-organizing
but I hadn't realized the significance
of this right salt sational
self-organization right and obviously
one of this has come from a steward
Kaufman who I think is quite brilliant
actually but that book was before the
self organizational things started to
come into biology and it was a very
vigorous perhaps too vigorous in places
argument or her discontinuity and so is
picked up and became that sort of you
know and it might well be in an
important book in intelligent design but
when I wrote the book I was looking for
us I think I found in nature's destiny a
route to explain the anomalies in
evolution where there are perhaps
discontinuities and and is that idea
growing in the kinda scientific iminium
yeah I think that in fact i think it's
gradually becoming accepted that the
universe is a very unique place in terms
of the laws of nature you know what
whether it's a fluke whether there's a
multiverse whether it's an imminent
intelligence and nature you know
whatever the explanation is i think
people are accepting the empirical facts
are this that the laws of nature you
know you know if you take a hammer
and you shape a hammer it's easy to
steal hammer a nail right but if you
look at the universe it's like a
precision clock you can't tamper with
the laws and still tell the time we're
going to get the design just right so
that's a different in a sort of Stone
Age hammer and a precision clock or what
we found is that in fact instead of
instead of life depending on a Roy
rather roughly hue and Hammer it depends
on a precision engineering in nature
right in an Internet shell and I think
that's generally accepted and there's a
huge range of them of explanations of
why there is design you know what where
this is you know how this fine tuning is
occurred but i think that the universe
is fine-tuned and if there was only one
universe that ever existed I think you'd
have to presume that it was there by
definitely by design right there have to
be an intelligence within nature or
intelligent about before we're just
still ignorant of a lot of the early
conditions of the universe and the
science is relatively new and I think
it's always okay to just say I don't
know or we don't know yet and here's six
different theories or twenty different
theories or whatever and start testing
them before we leap into saying it's
this one or that one simply because we
want it to be true always good to be
humble in the face of ignorance
sometimes I think and recognize and
we're still pretty new at the science
game it's only a couple centuries old
and so you know who knows how it will
turn out yeah and I'm not clear Michael
that I understand I mean sure the
universe has to be the way it is for us
to be here discussing it but nothing
logically follows from bad except that
we are here discussing it mm-hmm yes
that's right yes yeah yeah where do you
go from there but still still you could
have it could have been the case that a
vast range of parameters would allow us
to be here now we know that in fact it's
one choice in as Penrose says ten to one
hundred and twenty three unless there's
some underlying principle of physics
like a string theory but maybe not
string theory but something like that
you know that might explain it and it
makes perfect sense once we know how the
big bang began and therefore it gave
rise to this equation that you can fit
on a t-shirt that explains everything
and then those 27 different fine two
numbers all are explained by this one
equation and then that makes sense and
there's no our mystery left yeah I mean
it's also the elegance and duty of the
cosmos in the mathematical order of it
as well as judged by us which is
slightly subjective Sagan used to say
where carbon chauvinists yes because
we're made of car I mean based on carbon
it's next to impossible to think of how
life could be some other way and yet of
course it could yeah but I've been
hearing that argument here 30 years it's
rather like artificial intelligence as
always ten years time it happened you
know I I'm pretty convinced that the the
carbon atom plus water gives you unique
capacities to build complexity I'm not
sure I think we know enough about
chemistry now if there really was no
turned when is the same as mechanical
alternative lives I think you're going
to have to use at least
self-organization for self-replication
because the complexity of generating
highly complex struck the difficulty of
constructing highly complex systems
without self-organization in an
automated system is incredibly the field
imagine how that's done and so how many
self-organizing systems are going to
even incorporate in your life system I
don't know let's see I mean I don't know
you know but even if we were to accept
that this form of life is the only form
of life there could be and that the laws
of the universe have to be their way
they are for this form of life to be
possible all that would flow from that
is that things are what they are do it
doesn't it doesn't imply anything at all
if things have been different we
wouldn't be here discussing yes that's
what would flow it but but but but if
there was a vast number of alternative
life as possible you couldn't possibly
argue that carbon based life are we with
you know were the only life possible
right in other words if you wanted to
argue that the universe was constructed
for us right you have to first of all
show that there's only one possible life
possible in the cosmos right well I
don't know that you do I mean why do you
have to show why couldn't see God
because of those if it was ten if there
was ten different forms of life right if
we knew about them now you know
artificial life mechanical life borel
lights around life yeah of all these
four forms of life were well no
impossible you could never argue that
life on Earth or carbon-based
life was the sort of cosmic purpose for
the world was bio centricity for that
particular thing because there's so many
other alternatives right you couldn't
make that argument so at least not spin
it I think established well I mean I
don't know that it has been established
but it doesn't seem to me to be I mean
how do you establish that something is
not possible I don't know that you can
prove that negative and even as you say
even if we could prove that there were
other plausible forms of life that the
universe does not permit I still don't
see that that would have any broader
implications I don't think that would
change my metaphysics also the universe
is well not very well designed for what
supposing supposing oh yes 0 no no most
of the universe is completely empty
there's nothing there you can't live
anywhere it's mostly not designed for us
and and for the universe is 13.7 billion
years old and we're you know just a few
million years old is a hominid species
and so what was what was the purpose of
this universe for the first you know 30
years it doesn't it doesn't really look
like it's for us well I the best bet my
best guests future of science we're only
a flash in the pan we've only been
around for a hundred and thirty thousand
years and if we make it another 130,000
that will be very good going a miracle I
mean we will just have been like nanda
tars who are around for a few tens of
thousands of years will have done a
little bit better than that but we're
not likely to do marvelously well on any
kind of a scale and then back to nothing
long sleep I'm sleep after yeah well I
mean how many spacecraft have we sent a
couple dozen out to the planets and you
know we're pretty ignorant of what but
there's also strange things as well now
I think that in fact our existence is
slightly stranger than this in for
centuries from the birth of science
we've been we've penetrated into the
Atem penetrated with the far distances
of space our ability to handle
mathematics and science is an incredible
thing the correspondence between human
mind and reality is amazing we can
explode an atom I mean I think how
amazing that is well yeah but if some if
some finer intelligence came down from
another planet we may suddenly realize
how unbelievably stupid and ignorant we
are I don't know how
what is the scale by which we judge that
yeah that's right but I'm saying that in
fact i think is a widespread feeling the
correspondence between the fact that we
can understand nature and the way we do
i find very remarkable but but remember
the Copernican principle that we're not
special and it's that's one of those
counter intuitive ideas you have to
repeat like every day when you get a
rumor we're not special because our
propensity is to think we're the center
of everything and we've always thought
that that's that's certainly true i mean
i'm only making the point this is a work
in process yeah okay i mean we don't
know where this is going it may well be
we do find that you can make life from
silicon and there's all sorts of other
forms applied it may be that we find
that in other forms of intelligence or
the forms of cellular intelligence could
understand the cosmos like us we don't
know these things are speculative but i
am staggered at the success that humans
of hadn't science because there's
nothing in our evolutionary history that
teaches us about quantum mechanics the
mathematics accused in quantum mechanics
it's counterintuitive to all the sort of
simple logic of living in a tribal
village it's in fact we have to be we
have to have the mathematical have to
have the intellectual capacity for full
counterintuitive how science by the way
clive in your final statement isn't
there a program called I life oh there
it is that's the origins of life right
there it's here already all right well
switching to a different topic we've
been we've been discussing global
warming quite a bit at this conference
and I know that you've written about it
Michael and and you have some strong
opinions on it Michael Denton but and
the interesting thing is it seems as
though the scientific evidence that the
earth is warming and the human beings
are contributing to it is growing
stronger and stronger all the time and
yet there seems to be an ideological
divide where conservatives simply don't
believe it and liberals take it as the
gospel truth and I'm kind of an agnostic
myself as I'm stuck in the middle but
one of the things that I've never quite
understood that maybe you can clarify
for me is throughout the history of the
world bamba for Humanity showed up the
temperature fluctuated so much that the
glaciers came down from the polar caps
and covered the temperate zones and then
the climate warmed up
so much naturally that they receded back
to the polls again and this went on back
and forth long before anyone was driving
cars and operating refrigerators and so
forth and so so the question is I guess
I'll start with the skeptic here you
mentioned that you were hit you had been
skeptical about the potentially
catastrophic effects of global warming
but you're less so now yeah i think if
we break the problem down and do for
parts and don't call it global warming
call it global climate change that's
what the professionals do simply because
it isn't always getting warmer some
parts it's getting colder because of
more carbon dioxide so and the four the
four parts are is the earth getting
warmer yes everybody agrees on that what
is the cause of this warm a natural or
or human cause or some combination
probably a combination what's the
percentage who knows maybe 5050 6040 40
60 you know that's there's much great
debate there and the error bars start to
get a little wider the third what are
the long-term consequences short-term
versus long-term consequences of
whatever the change is going to be here
the error bars get even wider and our
uncertainty grows and and then the
fourth part is what do we do about it
and so in that case I think it's since
this is a libertarian conference i would
i would encourage us to at least take
market steps toward solving the problem
because for a whole host of reasons
including political and economic we
should not be dependent on fossil fuels
and oil there's a whole bunch of good
reasons why we shouldn't do that anyway
so why not assume there's going to be
some effect of carbon dioxide on the on
the climate and so let's go ahead and
start to clean it up and let's get the
market to do it before the government
sets up some manhattan size project matt
and project size thing to do it and that
so that's my take okay yeah i think we
should we should all hope the global
warming has been caused by human beings
because as you say there have been
several cycles ice ages deserts of
climate change that have had nothing to
do with human activity and that we would
be in no position to do anything to stop
if they come again as they most likely
will so let's hope that this global
warming is human caused because in that
case
human activity might be able to do
something to stabilize the situation
otherwise the only thing I can suggest
is investing in property in the
Highlands of Scotland because it's going
to be beautiful that the hinterlands of
Canada will be prime farmland yeah see
it's a good thing we should drive those
SUVs those maniacs I think I'd I tend to
agree with the sentiments expressed by
the other I think back to the what I
talked about before the convergence of
evidence that tells us how we know
evolution happen what's happened in the
last 15 years in climate research is
that there has been this convergence of
evidence for multiple lines of inquiry
lots of different ways to study how the
environment is changing whether it's
ecologist studying wind flowers come to
bloom or ornithologist studying when
birds begin to in the spring begin to
breed and so forth all the way down to
glacier glaciologists who do drill cores
in the Antarctica and geologists and
paleontologists and so and again it's
not like these guys I'll meet on the
weekend to say you know those
conservatives are going to try to cut
back on on our environmental protection
so we got to get our story straight here
on the global warming thing you know
they don't even know each other they
keep coming to the same conclusion and
this is what leads me to have a
reasonable amount of confidence that you
know it's real and probably at least
significantly caused by human activity
right now this would be an awfully
expensive problem to fix if indeed it's
real so so being three science guys are
reasonably well-informed would you say
yay or nay climate change is about to
eventually cause catastrophic change in
the earth or does the evidence not
support that what do you say Michael I
think from my reading of it is that we
have time to do something about it
gradually we don't have to do a
Manhattan Project size thing next year
to solve the problem typically the
doomsayers doomsayers on the right and
the left are usually wrong they
exaggerated by orders of magnitude of
when the doomsday is coming or doesn't
come at all so I think we have time okay
now I would be inclined to think that we
that we have time and that human
ingenuity which I don't want to downplay
will
be up to the task yeah I agree with this
as well I think also that in fact if you
look at the geological record what sorts
of changes have occurred for instance
it's amazing the oxygen levels have
changed from about fifteen percent to
twenty-eight percent in the geological
history the levels of calcium and
magnesium in the seas have changed quite
dramatically and it's of course this is
why I love log proposed the constancy is
remarkable that's why i love logged
proposed the sort of Gaia hypothesis
because it's extremely difficult if
there's so many minerals in the rocks
that so many feedback systems are so
many cycles but working out howdy how
the hydrosphere has maintained constancy
elemental constants in the ratios of
take a sodium calcium for a thousand
million years which has happened is
extraordinary then it seems that the
earth seems to be able to bring itself
back to these constant things so we we
increase carbon dioxide and the amount
of carbon dioxide we're releasing do you
know that ten percent of the crustal
rocks is dolomites and actual carbon set
of sediments it's a hundred trillion
tons of carbon in the rocks the entire
amount of carbon in the hydrosphere is
an infinitesimal fraction of that and
the dolomites are very soluble look at
cave the caves compared with quartz and
work modeling all this is extremely
difficult but we do know one thing for
certain the elemental constancy of the
Earth's hydrosphere has been maintained
by the Earth's natural phenomena natural
processes for a thousand million years
and there's been huge fluctuations in
temperature in oxygen levels and other
things but it keeps coming back to this
constant thing well yeah but that
doesn't mean to say that human life
gonna dive under those conditions yes
but life will probably life but not
human yeah it's a range that human life
is a very very small portion of the
range for life yes but even even when
these massive changes were occurring in
ice ages and things was always parts of
the world which had were relatively
habitable right and then in fact in the
ice ages I mean and as the climate
change in the Pleistocene during the the
six interglacials lines went to London
and they went down again so you know and
man can move as well you know so but I
take your point
that's it I think something should be I
think we should do something about it
but I also don't think that it's it
might never need to a catastrophe
because of the inbuilt inbuilt controls
in the planet but we don't know about
but we should do something about it okay
I wanted to give the audience a chance
to ask questions here at the microphone
so why don't we go ahead and start as
this is a free market conference i
thought i'd offer that another reason
for the resistance to evolution in this
country is probably associated with the
relatively high degree of religiosity
here compared to other developed
countries which itself is probably
fueled by the free market for religion
in this country which does not exist in
Europe and other developed countries
which have much more monolithic
doctrinal faith yeah but why why does
why does why do american christians feel
threatened by evolution in a way that
the Church of England never did Darwin
had this great anxiety that he was going
to be excommunicated and blackboard from
his club and goodness knows what but in
fact Darwin is buried in Westminster
Abbey when he died his friends
telegraphed the Dean of Westminster
Abbey who was on vacation in Italy and
he telegraphed back and in his um in in
the deans autobiography he wrote that he
responded with alacrity that he wanted
to see Darwin next and you wonder climb
you could say that the Church of England
is the religion you have when you don't
have a religious right I actually I
actually wanted to move off of that
topic the title for this session is the
future of science and technology so I
would like to introduce Ray Kurzweil to
this discussion on the assumption that
most all the panelists are familiar with
his work is thesis of the singularity
coming through technology and a
Concilium SAT nanotech and biotech and
computing power he's so confident about
this as you know Kurzweil is a very
accomplished inventor and a smart
thinker a little wacko in some ways I
think and he believed he's going to live
forever at least his brain will thanks
to the convergence of these technologies
growing rocked logarithmically what do
you all think of
yeah I was enjoying her Wiles work and
the the projection in the future of
trend lines which is what he does is
always interesting in clever but I'm
always skeptical because in the past
people that have done that have
typically been wrong and this whole idea
of as you mentioned artificial
intelligences 10 years away and always
will be is possible I mean these are
really hard problems and I'll tell you
what though if he's right but off a
little bit i'm gonna be really mad if it
turns out that we do achieve immortality
i missed it by like one year i think
that in fact basically i think the best
way to the most likely way to
immortality mrs. quite frightening might
be through stem cells i think this is
quite scary and from the genetic
knowledge of the various clocks that are
changing long liberty in mammals for
instance chimps on the best the best
situations never lived to more than
about 35 to 40 years well I'm made an
older chimp than that you have of you
yeah I've met a chimp in Florida who was
in one of the early Tarzan movies so was
alive in mid 1930s Wow there are a
couple of chimps getting into their
sixties and seventies well okay yeah
okay well that's they kept but anyway to
come back to the point of clocks we are
we are we are very close to working out
what changes the long livity of
different mammals in the general because
by comparisons was more more general
they're going to find the genes that do
it I mean wheel that we lived to 70
because in quite with for biologically
programmed to lift 70 and mouse lives
two three four other reasons because its
program to live two three this I think
is a scary thing and if you if you look
at the developments and genetics and you
marry this with stem cells I think that
we're into the into a situation when
it's not we won't find immortality
bikers wells methods we're going to find
immortality by fiddling with biology as
it is then i find this frankly if this
is going to happen this is going to be a
real revolution in human existence
interestingly the the sociology of
groups that go for that do tend to be
libertarian and non-theistic generally I
find because I've been following that
movement
a long time it's an interesting cohort
of people that are extremely positive
about science very optimistic about the
future which is all great but it's in on
another level it's very little different
from mainstream religions who harbor the
day when the second coming is coming and
will be rescue just like the left talks
about you know in the future we're going
to have this wonderful green environment
or or a classless society or whatever
the tendency to portray the future in
these sort of hedonic paradisiacal terms
is very natural the fact that you can
back it up with charts and graphs makes
it interesting from a science point of
view but it does it make it I think any
any truer send the other ones right next
question okay there are a lot of
economic doomsday scenarios floating
around and I was wondering what your
thoughts were on whether technology in
the next fifty or hundred years will
increase productivity enough and make
enough other types of advances that
possibly we could solve a lot of those
problems that are coming up like too
many old people and not enough people to
take care of or the monetary crisis and
so forth do you think technology at the
rate is accelerating will be able to
forestall a lot of these problems yeah
most of them hopefully I'm praying about
it I think I think people build the
technology that they want to have for
the to solve the problems that they see
themselves faced with so I think that's
one of the areas that a lot of
investment into technology will go
towards apart from the eye thingy yes
I'm here to speak for the skeptics
because you're not contrary to what you
said about there being a convergence of
evidence on global climate change I
don't think that that's correct i don't
think that there is any type of
consensus about whether the one degree
Fahrenheit change in the last century is
after anthropogenic or within you know
it's well within the range of natural
variability and there simply isn't a
consensus
and then to argue that we should impose
on ourselves the regulatory regime that
government wants to impose but if we do
it ourselves somehow it's better seems
it seems questionable to me yeah she's
an interesting point there Michael just
because you you say you used to be more
skeptical about global warming and that
you're more convinced which means you've
seen evidence would seem to make you
feel that there's a there is a greater
chance that we're going to see some kind
of dramatic yeah i mean i don't really
have a dog in this fight is where i
don't it doesn't matter to me i haven't
committed to anything i'm not a climate
scientist I've just been sort of
observing it from the sidelines and it
seems to me that if you if you read the
papers and you talk to professional
climate scientists most of them would
agree with my little four-point thing
yes you could find in the sort of Fringe
literature handful of skeptics Richard
linds and at MIT is about the only one
you ever see from a real University who
is paraded on TV and the reason he's
always on TV is because he's like the
only one left and so while it's true you
can always find a few skeptics to go
counter I'm looking at sort of the
preponderance of evidence or words
tending the lead admitting that the
error bars as we move away from the hard
science to the political implications or
whatever but on your final point I would
I would return to our our guests here at
the conference John Mackey CEO of whole
foods and who presents this why not take
a moral stand as a capitalist and do
things that are good for people good for
the poor good for the environment I mean
these are all good things to do whether
any of this stuff regardless of what the
data says who likes to breathe carbon
dioxide I live in LA who likes to
breathe that air the point is that
number one the air is cleaner now than
it was 30 40 years ago or two that there
is anything moral about foreclosing
people's choices and that's essentially
what a good number of these you know
so-called environmental you know
dictates really are and
I can out challenge you to say that
lindzen is not the only person who's
challenging the idea that it's
anthropogenic well are dozens and dozens
of climate scientists who will disagree
who will say that yes we know that
there's been a rise in temperature but
it's within the natural variability we
don't know whether it's anthropogenic
maybe it is maybe it isn't but we don't
know and we don't know what the
long-term consequence will be there are
benefits as I would give a plug here for
since his book book TV for Tim Flannery
spoke the weather makers for my money it
was the best single summary of the data
and the evidence that I've seen yet
that's a highly readable book as well
what book is that it's called the
weather makers by Tim Flannery he's a
Australian climate scientist okay okay
here's a short question despite the fact
that Reverend maltos may have been
proven wrong but still a lot of people
underfed in the world and dying from
lack of food do you think that
technology will develop maybe a pill
that people can take three times a day
and not have to grow food and I'm go
through and wait for the whole cycle
well you know that is Jetsons did it
Simon Greene I had I didn't quite catch
it would we eventually have a pill
instead of eating something like that
yeah technologically speaking here I
kind of like Gillian Simon's approach
that more people is not bad it's good
this is human resources and look what
we've been able to do since the Green
Revolution and just the last 50 years
the productivity of food is even though
there's fewer fewer people working in
food production we have more and more
food I think that's one of those nice
trend lines that trans positively in
favor of market solutions to these kinds
of problems yes sir yes so spacious
seems to be the only criteria for the
alarm opposed about possible climate
change where's the debate about what's
the best climate debate about what's the
best climate we have it in Los Angeles
so that's it Oh have you ever bleep of
it in Perth I was
slive says he's always a little chilly
anyway sorry see Clive says he's always
a little chilly anyway you favorite yeah
I think Perth Western Australia has the
best climate I'd have to second to
Michael on that so it's the only city
with its own air conditioning sea breeze
its marbles it's almost Burroughs yeah
yeah pretty much I mean it actually is
an interesting question because it you
sort of intuitively think well what's
wrong with it being a little bit warmer
Canada would be you know you could do
more farming there something like that
flannery's has a chapter on this and the
weather makers that in fact even a few
degrees increase yes of course it
Canada's slightly warmer but it also
causes huge monsoons and and hurricanes
and whatnot in equatorial climates where
most of the food production actually
happens so although it might be nicer in
Canada it will be much worse in the most
productive food areas that's that's the
counter-argument to that ok well the
questions are over and we're out of time
so that our timing is impeccable thanks
so much for being here thank you